If I get a text, I look at my phone.
It's definitely texting.
Instagram, Twitter, Facebook.
Snapchat.
I do Snapchat and drive sometimes.
Justin, nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you.
I just really quickly wanna have a chat to tell you what happened to me.
When I was 21 years old, driving home from my college graduation ceremony,...
...a driver on his phone was so distracted,...
...he turned left into the intersection at a red light.
Another car, an 18-wheeler, swerved to miss him and hit my family's car.
The resulting collision actually killed both of my parents.
I spent two months in the hospital fighting for my own life...
...and then two more months in a rehab hospital.
Honestly, if I have been sitting at a red light,...
...I'll like, glance down to see if my mom's texting me,...
...but the people's lives that are impacted from something that's so stupid...
I can assure you on my drive home right now,...
...I'm not going to use my phone and drive.
And I'm not gonna do it when I go to work tomorrow...
...and the next day after that, until it becomes a habit and it just doesn't happen at all.